hey what's up guys my name is Jono and
woke with episode 42 of game programming
so today we're going to take a look at
the input methods for our player thing
now playing sends mob right now and what
mob doesn't have at this point is a
movement we talked about this last time
and it doesn't have a move it does have
a move method alright that's what we're
going to talk about today moving so in
other words to make our player move you
know via input which which we will cover
eventually we actually need to make a
move method first of all and this move
method is going to control how you know
how pixels are translated on the screen
so if we actually go into our entity
class entity Java you can see that we've
actually got X&Y and of course these
these integers x and y these two
variables they control the location of a
particular entity on our map now when a
mob moves so when the mob or any any
player and anything really on the screen
any character actually moves the x and y
variables for its location need to
change so yeah that's that's the basis
of this so first of all move needs move
needs to actually take two parameters
the X change so in other words how it
changes on the x axis and how its
position changes on the y axis so int X
a just because X X is already taken and
why a alright so X a is going to
basically tell our our game which way
the player moves on the x axis if he
even moves on the x axis and sorry I
don't mean player I mean any mob and y
is going to tell us our which way we
move on the y axis so in other words
these these two really have three states
all right one is is going up sorry with
X it's going left not moving at all or
going right with Y it's going up not
moving at all or going down okay so that
makes sense
three different possible things right so
to explain this more
well I guess you'll you'll see it in a
minute but that's actually a few ways we
need to sort of handle this on its most
basic form is simply X plus equals x a
and y plus equals y a that is the most
basic form of the movement of the move
method however that doesn't exactly end
up working brilliantly unfortunately you
know but if you look at this you can um
you can sort of see how it works now to
sort of elaborate on that what you'll
actually have to do is you'll see that
into these two parameters we actually
plug in either negative 1 0 or 1 ok now
when we put negative 1 that's going to
mean that it's actually going to if we
put an if you put if we put these
variables into let's just say X if we
actually put negative 1 it's just going
to subtract 1 from the x variable if we
put 0 1 it's not going to do anything to
the X variable and if we put in a 1 here
then it's actually going to add one
pixel another will be one unit it is in
it is in turn the one pixel to our X
variable which holds location so in
other words if we put one here it's
going to move to the right one one spot
I guess if we put 0 in something we're
all and if we put negative 1 it's
actually going to move to the left and
that is sort of how it works that's what
that is the three numbers that we plug
in now unfortunately doesn't exactly
work that way one thing we need to do is
actually um I'm not actually going to do
this now just because it's well where I
really want to demonstrate what happens
but one other big thing that we need to
do is actually handle collision so in
other words we only allow us to actually
move if disclosure so in other words if
there's no collision so if the collision
thing returns false then we move all
right just like that of course the
collision will have to be expanded in
the future but that is sort of how it
works right now all right so in other
words if there's no collision we move
the other thing we actually want to keep
track of is the direction that we're
moving and so if I type in
over here just simply protected we've
already got direction here my bad
already got a direction variable great
what I actually want to do is actually
use this move method to to determine
which direction the mob is moving in so
in other words the way we do that is we
simply say that of course if X a is
actually greater than one
sorry greater than zero some of the
words if it's a positive number we're
going to moving we're going to be moving
to the right if it's a negative number
we're going to be moving to the left so
the way we actually set that is think of
it as a compass so zero is up and we're
just going clockwise so zero was up one
is east or right two is South or bottom
or down other not bottom down and three
of course is West or left so in other
words direction is going to equal 1 if X
a is less than zero direction is going
to equal three right that's West if Y a
if Y is greater than zero so in other
words if Y is actually going um is
increasing it's going down so therefore
the directions an equal to which is
south and finally if y is less than zero
then the direction is going to equal
zero because we're going up that's north
and that is how direction moved that is
how the direction moves alright and
you'll see that I'll actually put these
things up into like the the debug screen
or something so that you guys can
actually see how that works but
basically you should be able to UM to
tell if this makes sense leave a comment
telling me it makes sense because it
sounds like it makes sense in my head we
of course you know may be going too fast
or something just let me know but yeah
that is that is how that works so once
again you know we input these two
variables into here which is basically
the direction that we need to move in
combined that's what they give us we we
also use this little series of if
statements to determine which direction
we move in and don't tell me to use a
switch statement this is much better
and finally yep so that that gives us
the direction in which we have to move
in and this collision thing basically
checks for collision so it says if there
is no collision the
and increase those variables over here
so our x and y variables which are our
location for the mobs on other words
move the absent mob if it passes all
these tests which for now is just
collision but yeah that is that is
episode 42 of game programming guys I'm
actually taking a quick break over the
holiday season I'll be back soon we
might miss one or two episodes but I'm
not exactly sure when I'm going to
resume this but give me a few days all
right
I've spent some time with my family so
yeah but um after I actually returned
after that holiday break game
programming is gonna go back to being a
daily show so there you go that's your
Christmas present so yeah anyway I miss
I miss I wish you guys a happy holidays
you know a Merry Christmas and a Happy
New Year and it is actually Christmas
Eve right now I'm recording this but
yeah I'll see you guys I'll see you guys
probably in the new year so I hope you
enjoyed this episode of game programming
if you did please hit that like button
leave a comment saying Merry Christmas
Happy New Year whatever it is you want
to do Happy Holidays
um and yeah just say Merry Christmas to
eachother there'd be a big big happy
community so I'll see you guys next time
later